[Music]
stop they like stuff and I want more
stuff my child hearken to my voice which
is I Socrates oh no what do you want I
haven't seen you at the symposium of
late well yeah because you kind of hate
women and it was getting me down my
child without my guidance you have
become a slave to mirror appetite have
you forgotten what I've taught you about
the true meaning of happiness the
rational contemplation of truth and
justice look I tried that and honestly I
don't think it's really my thing I'm a
dumb-dumb and I like shiny things ah my
child
these are pleasures for the pigs
happiness can only be acquired through
the contemplation of beauty itself
perfectly exemplified in the supple
bodies of young boys okay thank you for
your feedback we'll take that into
consideration
look Greeks look we all have wants needs
desires and we all want happiness but
happiness what does that word even mean
I'm just a dumb tongue who likes shiny
things and these are questions really
better left to the philosophers which is
why I'm not going to present my original
ideas in this video instead I will be
interpreting one of the most influential
works of anti-capitalist philosophy ever
produced a series in multiple volumes
that examines deeply the concept of the
fetishism of the commodity I am of
course talking about worth it a series
on BuzzFeed video about three men who
are younger than me who travel the world
and try different foods that cost
different amounts of money and then say
whether it was worth it in each episode
they taste a type of food at three
different restaurants a three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
for example they compare a $2.00 pizza
to a $2,000 pizza that's made of gold
and a $1 ice cream to a $1,000 ice cream
that's made of gold in a $1 bagel to a
$1000 bagel that's made of gold it is a
lot of gold what do I do it than gold on
my fingers a tag on chip renewal now to
the untrained eye worth it may seem like
insipid YouTube click father but we
intellectuals well we have a taste for
insights that penetrate a little deeper
we like to take it all in ah the worth
it boys Andrew Adams demon these are not
new content creators mere actors
dancing monkeys performing for odd
revenue they're philosophers
spiritual leaders even and what they've
accomplished on YouTube
quite honestly far surpasses the
combined insights of Marx Engels Lenin
Sarge
Trotsky Luxemburg Graham XI Lukacs
Zarathustra and even our dear Brett mom
Kropotkin I've of course read each of
these great thinkers Complete Works many
many times but I always come away
dissatisfied and I find myself returning
yet again to the unparalleled master
works of Andrew Adam and Steve see each
episode of worth it poses to the viewer
a fundamental question is it worth it we
may never know take for instance the
case of the two dollar pizza versus the
2000 dollar gold pizza which is the
better deal I mean how would we even
begin to answer such a perplexing riddle
well according to Karl Marx the value of
a commodity must be understood in two
ways on the one hand there's the youth's
value the commodities capacity to
satisfy some human need and on the other
hand there is the exchange value the
quantity determining the ratio by which
a commodity is exchangeable with every
other commodity deriving from
objectified labour over time and
expressed in terms of price so let's not
oversimplify things clearly and true
Adam and Steve are inviting us the
viewers of worth it to understand the
use value exchange
value dichotomy not as a mere
hierarchical binary but as a sort of
delusion rhizome a non arborescent
multiplicity with as many sinuous
interconnections as the truffles on the
pizza itself am I making myself clear
I'm not it's almost as if the
philosophers are simply burdening me
with jargon and not actually helping me
think through this any better so let's
throw philosophy in the trash and start
over from the beginning
foxes I like stuff and I like shiny
things
now that's something everyone can
understand so let's take that as the
first axiom of the economic theory I'll
be developing in this video so given
that I like stuff and I like shiny
things let's return to the question is a
2000 dollar pizza worth it well it is
covered in gold and gold is shiny so I
do like that but the pizza itself seems
kind of gross it's got squid ink dough
smeared with foie gras Stilton cheese
black truffles gold flakes and caviar
these flavors are overwhelming and they
don't make any sense together the only
thing they have in common is being
really expensive and it's like the
culinary equivalent of Donald Trump's
apartment but Andrew and Stephen sit
there with New York's financial district
for a backdrop and they try to pretend
that the pizza doesn't taste like gold
and shed
I'm honestly speechless I feel weird is
it the gold
I just ate two hundred and fifty dollars
I feel kinda like like I'm committing a
crime and that's what
$1,250 looks like there's this kind of
sadness that sets in as they realized
that the $2,000 Pizza isn't worth it at
all and they start to feel almost like
they've done something immoral it's a
feeling I've had many times myself after
spending too much money on some gilded
piece of trash in a vain attempt to fill
the hollow in my soul is their name for
that feeling well I like to call it
[ __ ] neoliberalism an opposed to
scarcity luxury communist utopia a bad
pizza covered in gold would just be a
bad pizza covered in gold you might be
mad at the chef for making a
disappointing pizza but you probably
wouldn't be overcome with feelings of
emptiness and guilt to fully understand
why a 2,000 dollar pizza is not worth it
you have to understand it in the context
of capitalism the price $2,000 tells you
the exchange value of the pizza and if
you live in America you have an
instinctive sense for what that means
because you know all the other things
you could buy with $2,000
for a lot of people $2,000 would buy a
few months of food or health care or
golden nails and there's a lot of
families who sit around the kitchen
table every evening worrying about how
they're gonna afford golden nails and
it's that awareness that makes the
shitty $2,000 Pizza seem not just
aesthetically disappointing but almost
obscene or even immoral but of course to
call it immoral is actually to
misidentify the real problem so it's not
like those shitty YouTube comments that
go pizzas in Africa could have eaten
those children how dare you because the
problem isn't that Andrew Adam and
Steven are bad people for buying an
expensive flat bread smeared with gilded
cream cheese the problem is our economy
fundamentally operates in a way that
makes inevitable these repulsive
juxtapositions of scarcity and abundance
that's why I don't really agree with a
philosopher Peter Singer who has this
idea that many of the world's problems
could be solved if privileged American
college students would just become hedge
fund managers and donate most of their
income to buying mesquite
in the Congo I mean sure that would
probably help with certain situations
but it's not gonna change the fact that
the global economy is structured around
cheap exploited labor at the bottom and
$2,000 pizzas at the top another way to
approach this issue might be to ask who
are the goddamn reptiles well they're
certainly not the Jews I want to be
clear get everyone on the same page that
I'm not blaming the Jews for anything
except you know cooking the white race
but to be fair is someone had to cook
them the white race has really been
getting on my nerves lately so the
lizards are not the Jews they're not
reptilians from alpha Draconis they're
not freemasons or globalists or the gay
agenda but the key insight is that
they're not even really the capitalists
the lizards are capital itself and what
does that mean well I don't know but it
does make me sound like I've read a lot
of Marx doesn't have what I'm trying to
say is that the problems with our
economy are not just the product of
greed or some other personal moral
defect of the wealthy of course some
capitalists are terrible people but some
probably aren't and either way the
virtues or vices of the rich are sort of
beside the point so the real point of
the golden pizza is that it's emblematic
of the fact that the extreme economic
inequalities of our society are
laughably unjustifiable if I were to
translate the meaning of the golden
pizza into an argument so it goes
something like this
capitalism as we know it is a defective
economic system because although it's
good at creating large amounts of wealth
it distributes that wealth in an
incredibly inefficient way where
efficiency is understood not as the
capacity to maximize total wealth but as
the capacity to maximize human happiness
now I need to explain what I mean about
happiness here's a question should the
economy serve humanity or should
humanity serve the economy it seems
obvious to me that the economy should
serve humanity so what I look for in a
good economic system is that it produces
the most happiness for the people who
are a part of it so if you're willing to
go along with this the first question we
should ask is does having more wealth
make people happier and we actually have
data about that at least within the
context of our own economics
and the data shows that more income does
lead to more happiness up to a certain
point but the happiness benefit of
increased income Plateau is somewhere
between 65 and 95 thousand dollars a
year one interpretation of the reason
why happiness increases up to the
threshold is that at lower income levels
more income means less stress about
paying rent or mortgages or medical
bills or college tuition but once you
pass the threshold more income basically
just translates into more disappointing
golden pizzas if that interpretation is
correct and the current income
distribution seems really irrational at
least if the goal is to maximize
happiness the income distribution in the
United States is skewed toward the upper
extreme so that the national mean income
is around 72 thousand dollars right in
the plateau zone but the national median
income is around 59 thousand dollars
significantly below it furthermore 1% of
the population or making more than three
hundred and eighty-nine thousand dollars
a year several times the peak happiness
threshold so at least am i naive eyes
what it looks like is that millions of
people in this country don't have enough
money to securely afford food housing
education and health care well a few
million others are like constantly
gorging themselves on golden pizzas or
something but I'm guessing it's even
worse than that because it's not just
that some people don't have enough money
to meet all their needs it's that they
have to be poor while other people are
rich and since people compare themselves
to others that leads to all kinds of
additional anxieties and resentments and
social tensions is a study of capuchin
monkey that shows if you reward one
monkey for a task with a delicious grape
and a monkey in the adjacent cage with a
shitty hue convert the monkey who gets
the cucumber loses his shed and if you
do this to humans for long enough they
start building guillotines well that's
just how it looks to me I could be wrong
I mean I'm not an economic theorist and
honestly I don't really understand how
the economy works
I don't even check my own bank account
balance very often I make the video as I
swipe the card so look if I'm wrong and
capitalism is good actually just to
leave a comment and I'll be happy to be
proven wrong but before you do that
let's get some of the more obvious
objections
the way income inequality exists because
not everyone does the same jobs some
people work harder than others and those
people deserve to make more money
well the sweatshop workers work really
hard and they barely make any money at
all and a lot of people who work minimum
wage have to work multiple jobs just to
sustain themselves and their families
it's actually a ton of work and they
barely make enough money to survive but
minimum wage workers are unskilled
workers why would anyone become an
innovator or medical researcher if they
could make a good living as a janitor
well janitorial work is pretty important
actually someone has to cook and clean
and I think people who do such necessary
work deserve a decent living but I also
think a lot of people would find
janitorial work boring and I think that
the kind of personality that likes to
innovate and invent often isn't driven
mainly by profit anyway Jonas Salk never
patented his polio vaccine even though
he could have made millions of dollars
from it because he just cared about
humanity and he was driven by a purpose
beyond personal profit in fact a lot of
great historical scientists were
upper-class people who didn't need to
work for a living at all and were just
driven by their own passion and
curiosity so let me get this straight
you criticize capitalism and yet you
yourself make money on the internet
hypocrite much a few years ago I was a
broke philosophy graduate student and
when I criticized capitalism then people
used to say why don't you stop whining
and get a real job and earn a living you
just present capitalism because you're
too lazy to put in the work it takes to
succeed so if people who are failing
under capitalism can't criticize it
because they're just resentful and
people who are succeeding under
capitalism can criticize it because
they're hypocrites then according to you
is anyone allowed to criticize
capitalism capitalism may have problems
but it's the best economic system there
is you wouldn't want to live in Soviet
Russia or Maoist China would you well no
I wouldn't
hello I'm Tatiana thank you :
defense dalam [ __ ] off Bosley Daniel
fascist so granted a lot of past
communist regimes were shitty but that
doesn't mean that the current system is
the best and final system for all time
my approach to this topic is not to try
to resurrect soviet communism or
anything like that but rather to
identify problems with the current
system that seemed to cause unhappiness
and instability okay but I like stuff I
like stuff too I think a lot of people
have this instinctive fear that a
capitalism goes so does everything we
love I mean when I think of communism in
particular I think of austerity scarcity
conformity undrinkable victory gin the
end of fashion all art required to be
propaganda just an all-around nightmare
situation for a person of my persuasion
it's not for no reason at all that I
have these anxieties since there was an
aspect of that to some past communist
societies but this stuff I'm worried
about booze makeup art baths these
things existed long before capitalism
and they'll exist long after it and I
know different types of people will have
different things they're concerned about
straight guys will be like will there be
video games after capitalism Oh God and
yeah there will be Tetris is a Soviet
game and it's one of the best games of
the 80s
[Music]
some of the stuff we like could probably
even be improved if it were liberated
from capitalist pressures I mean look
with capitalism and the pressure to turn
a profit has done two movies the last
time I was reading the only book I've
ever read two ways of seeing by John
Berger I noticed this description of
glamour in the context of advertising
its promise is not a pleasure but of
happiness happiness as judged from the
outside by others the happiness of being
envied is glamour and I felt kind of
attacked because glamour is very
important to us and by us I mean the
gays the owls the G's the bees the t's
and all those filthy filthy queues but
isn't it kind of true that at least in
advertising the function of glamour is
to provoke feelings of envy and
inadequacy and the beholder in the
service of selling you [ __ ] but the
advertising function I think is an
appropriation of glamour not something
essential to it and maybe glamour would
actually be liberated if it weren't
constantly conflated with advertising
so I guess my message to socialists of
the world is that actually stuff is good
glamour is good videogames are good
luxury is good guys are good I mean even
gold is good if you don't abuse it
horribly you know the most offensive
thing about the golden pizza is
ultimately that the $2 pizza is actually
better the golden pizza is an affront
not just of the people whose medical
bills that could have paid but it's an
affront to gustatory pleasure itself so
I guess my final take here is actually
champagne socialism is good but I'm not
talking about the champagne classes
becoming social I'm talking about
redistributing
the goddamn champagne all right now that
I've gotten these objections out of the
way I'm finally ready to get started
part one which you've all been waiting
for how to end capitalism once and for
all
well I don't know who do you people
think I am I'm a socially conscious
youtube entertainer not transsexual
Gandhi I mean according to Marxism we
can't just start the revolution whenever
we feel like it capitalism has to fail
and that'll bring about the conditions
that make revolution inevitable so I
guess we just try to relax and wait for
that to happen
sure it's bound to happen any day now
[Music]
you know maybe we should do something in
the meantime
uh so I don't know I guess vote labor
tweet radically try to eat more
vegetables
try not to be manipulated into waging
war against other downtrodden people and
can we please not hand more power to the
absolute worst dingbats our society has
on offer no no voting smashing well you
know what some she's the one with a plan
apparently I guess just do whatever she
says
[Music]
Bobby why don't you go take a bath real
good kitty don't close the door dear
comrades the central capital committee
has determined that contra points is and
always has been
counter-revolutionary Wu Shuang
revisionism the Department of
information has therefore replaced the
remainder of this video with a tribute
to the immortal science of Tapia
[Music]